charlie hedrick souhaite aumônier dans
une centrale de la région parisienne et
robert mans s'est tu viens de publier un
livre qui s'appelle tendre voyou et qui
raconte son expérience et une histoire
on peut dire c'est une histoire qu'on
quoi c'était un mec plutôt sympa ouais
c'est un jour et a tiré sur un flic
entre art comment ça s'est passé
bon bah c'est toute une aventure si tu
veux bon bah moi c'est la cdc a commencé
par déjà les orphelinats la petite
délinquance et puis ensuite il ya un
passage disons tranquille de ma vie et
je suis tombé dans la grande délinquance
un moment où si tu veux j'avais des
problèmes financiers
moi j'ai été entraîné par quelqu'un
enfin je vais pas te raconter toute
l'histoire de bouquins mais j'ai lu le
bouquin oui il ya un type qui est dit
dans le france a besoin d'argent pour le
faire un casse voilà d'aller à l'époque
tu vis en allemagne y en a vous allez
faire un casse en france puis voilà puis
ça se passe mal au secteur
moi c'est ça cet hiver et puis voilà en
sortant de la banque
tu tires sur impliqué jusqu'à la fin
d'année on sait pas si tu l'as tuée ou
non parce qu'un départ or il faut croire
que tu l'as tu es bon départ dans c'est
à dire attends au départ quand j'étais
en cavale je suis donc en cavale je ne
savais pas si je l'avais tué parce que
je les ai vu basculer bon bah tu sais
ans
on va pas vérifier puis en plus de ça
irait ses collègues qui étaient derrière
avec la sulfateuse bon bah je me suis
cassé le plus possible et puis donc a
commencé ma cavale de simone allemagne
c'est là que je suis tombé vraiment dans
le romantisme bon match au total j'ai
fait quatre salles d'autres à la fin
quand je me fais prendre donc par les
anti gang de ses soeurs nanan embrasser
mes gosses parce que bon vous pouvez
faire un décès un fourgon postal d'une
affaire suicidaire puis je croyais pas
rebondir lironde ouais mais s'est écrié
pas au programme
je croyais pas ça fait combien d'années
de taux bas si tu veux au total j'ai
pris 18 ans et demi j'ai fait donc neuf
ans et trois mois en france j'ai pris 15
ans les six domaines et j'ai fait donc
le res des onze années en allemagne 11
années le reste des ondes avec elle à
lyon samples et j'avais 25 ans et quand
elle sortait pas 36 piges passe comment
ça se passe les prisons les prisons d'un
site un monde dans un monde froid tu
pourrais me en parler que moi charlie un
toit tié tié depuis des années dans les
prisons sud depuis le 1er octobre 83
c'est une scène centrale
c'est les longues peines et des
condamnés à mort gracié des perpète des
vingt ans et des dix ans c'est assez
répressif d'hermès qui dit dans son
bouquin je viens il suffit d'aller en
prison pour tenir un vrai truand pour la
fin de ses jours
c'est à dire il ya une grande
promiscuité et puis il ya une chape de
plomb de silence monde est difficile de
percer le salon à présent commencer le
sexe du c'est soit tu es homosexuel ou
soit tu te satisfait toi-même bon moi je
me satisfais moi même mais c'est pas la
mort c'est d'être homosexuel nom n'est
pas forcé mais sans courage et aussi non
seulement une obsession sexuelle parce
que c'est une castration tous enfermés
exactement
bon bah si tu veux j'en parle aussi dans
mon bouquin j'ai été forcé de planter un
mec dans les douches qui voulait qu'ils
voulaient avoir quelque chose de moi que
je suis là pour lui d'aller dans ton
livre vient pas du tout d'obsession
sexuelle beige et noir non j'avais
j'avais une pointe ce qu'on appelle une
pointe à une petite pointe comme
beaucoup de détenus en ont dans les
longues peines et qu'il y voyait une
fois passé ses fesses et fak une lame
quoi sert la main gilles hamelin mais ça
non je vais planter carrément ah bon
donc ya pas eu d'histoire bah non parce
que il n'a pas été moucharder puis ça au
mieux pour lui parce que mes copains
quand même si tu vends le clan des
braqueurs c'est qu'il ya une grande
solidarité
ah ouais mais c'est déjà plein ce serait
quoi la solution pour un mec comme toi
si c'est de [ __ ] en taule à la
solution ont battu celle à ses surnoms
c'est à dire que tu as un problème
quotidien sur un fil et qu'est ce qu'il
faut faire
ah oui dans ce cas la huitième dire la
prison est une honte je dis pas que
c'est non mais non mais a priori non
mélangés qu'avant alors je vais les gens
qui n'y sont des filles qu'est ce qu'il
faut faire
alors je vais te dire donc ma site c'est
très simple tu regarde par exemple les
prises en allemagne sur des prises en
suède en norvège au danemark 1
c'est considéré déjà l'être humain comme
un être humain c'est pas lui enlever sa
dignité d'homme et en france mais dans
cette cité dans ces pays là il y en a
moins
c'est bizarre j'ai pas mais c'est comme
ça et je vais te dire les ya pas de ont
fait venir une fois par semaine les
femmes viennent avait rejoint de leurs
maris sont des cellules spéciales ce qui
est exact l'espagne
ils ont des contacts sexuels tout à fait
normal je voue sa sublime
en france par contre on en fait remonte
au prix de tout on insulte honteux
brisson te casses et puis voilà et puis
après on dit des maires de toi la
deuxième façon de ressentir en dehors de
ta rage de vivre qui a commencé très
jeune c'est quand même la fois c'est
quand même la religion c'est vrai hier
basse et surtout j'ai beaucoup pris en
prison j'ai découvert si tu veux j'ai
découvert la foi en taule c'est marrant
mais c'est comme ça parce qu'elle est en
prison j'étais sage avait plus rien et
j'ai tenté de me raccrocher à quelque
chose et j'ai trouvé
j'ai trouvé des des jambons en vendée en
les aumôniers donc protestants j'étais
protestants donc en plus de ça une
petite anecdote c'est qu'au départ tu
sais quand j'étais en maison d'arrêt le
maudit n'avait même pas été prévenus que
j'étais arrivé parce que bon ça passe
par les bris car qui sait comment c'est
les brigadiers un strap et débris car et
ils n'aiment pas ils n'aiment pas que tu
que tu t'en sors 10ème voit que ça te
fait que tu aies des petits plaisirs il
n'avait même pas 10 à l'aumônier
protestant que j'étais là et ça s'est
fait tout à fait par hasard chez tommy
tard quand j'ai fait deux ans de me
taire dans toute ma détention parce que
je me suis toujours battue si tu veux
pour les droits de l'homme en prison
j'étais écrivain public à metz tout ça
mais je voudrai toujours ma gueule pour
les autres et ce qui fait que moi je
plongeais mais enfin ça c'est pas grave
si vous n'êtes pas alors donc j'étais au
mythe heures et l'aumônier passait par
hasard voir un collègue qui était dans
le mitard à côté et puis j'entends
j'entends l'aumônier protestant là moi
je tape à la porte et puis moi aussi je
suis protestant des joueurs j'avais
envie de voir quelqu'un c'est pas
marrant et on en reste à 45 jours plus
tard nathan ces 30 jours je crois en mon
temps c'est 45 jours des fois ils
cumulaient toi
wright faisait sortir une journée et
faisait retomber le lendemain se faisait
ça faisait 90 jours d'affilée c'était
vraiment horrible et donc il m'a ouvert
la porte et puis voilà tu en as peur que
machin mais tu veux une clope c'est
interdit cigarettes maintenant
s'autoriser un je connais dans l'élite à
lessive il va pas c'est quoi alors mais
moi je porte la lecture biblique et je
prie avec ceux qui veulent prier mais ce
n'est le droit de porter rien du tout
non mais si l'infraction il dira pas
n'importe quoi moi je vais vous dire
monsieur monsieur cazalis m'importait du
chocolat m'apporter des clubs va rater
du pain d'épicés tout ça parce qu'on
était bien content de bouffer et enfouis
ma serviette alors
il a tenté je peux inventer des minivans
je peux donner la bible en tant que
chrétien ça vous révolte la façon dont
on les traite en prison j'aimerais qu'on
les considère comme des êtres humains
c'est voulu essayer de faire en
apportant de la lumière de l'air pur
dans cette prison mais l'administration
pénitentiaire il faut pas la condamner
en bloc d un accent très humain c'est
comme partout il ya une sorte de toutes
sortes de données de surveillance
mais le problème c'est que si tu veux il
ya des bons et des mauvais comme il dit
je suis d'accord avec lui comme il ya
des bons et des mauvais flics quand il
ya des bons et des mauvais magistrat
mais il ya plus de mauvais que de bon
cette fois que découvert en prison tu
continues à la la vive depuis la sortie
de crise ah oui c'est à dire que si tu
veux comme qu'on me parle de la bi tous
âges et lullaby d'ailleurs une dizaine
de fois deux voies
je la connais très bien je meilleur
passage que je préfère c'est
l'apocalypse
j'adore l'apocalypse ah oui oui parce
que c'est le passage le plus dur à
expliquer à vivre connu exactement
wallis et persécutions voilà si j'étais
toi producteurs destination finale c'est
simple c'est terrible c'est
qu'aujourd'hui faut aller en prison pour
découvrir la fois fiables bah oui
automates d'ailleurs c'est pas
automatique mais enfin il faut être mal
ouais ouais ouais y'a des gens s'étaient
bien qu'ils découlent c'est pourquoi
j'ai une fois la province enregistre de
8h justement à metz le brixia rémy tu
sais tu en prison on a le droit 10% de
pertes c'est comme à l'armée
ouais et je crois que j'allais crever
vraiment parce que je ne sais pas si
j'étais jeune au mitan de meise ducasse
que c'est ce machin et je suis met à
prier vraiment voix et
j'ai tenu le coup puis je m'en sors pas
trop mal comment sa valeur depuis que tu
es sorti ça va bien j'ai écris donc
tendre voyou j'ai fini mon deuxième
livre déjà qu'il s'appelle le tueur et
j'attaque un troisième qui s'appelle dit
suis fâché le malfrat si tu veux bomba
jeune idole dans la littérature c'est
auguste le breton l'état pas peur en
écrivant des livres qui s'appelle le
tueur dont la vocation à des mecs qui
vont faire après onze ans de taule bon
ben j'ai côtoyé ce monde de voyous
oui de trion si tu veux grâce grâce à
l'administration française
alors maintenant je n'ai plus qu'un seul
moyen pour m'en sortir c'est continuer à
écrire je regarde toi que tu retombes
raja mais là tu sais j'habite avenue du
maine et je vais faire sur un pèlerinage
à la santé s'était achevée autour de la
santé et je respire parce qu'il faut pas
oublier je crois que c'est des choses
qu'il faut promouvoir là on n'a pas le
droit d'oublier les corrections de ne
rien rater de l'inaptitude abonnez vous
mettez un pouce bleus